i'm seen as wolf blitzer and you're in
the situation room we're following
breaking news
it's election night i mean opening night
of the 2020-21
nba season like everything else this
year the nba is fluid
and always changing so let's bring in
cnn's john king he's here with me over
at the magic
wall to break down all the late-breaking
developments and we're following key
teams that have flipped players
in the very brief off-season welcome to
the nba
opening night situation room
and john our viewers here in the united
states and around the world are probably
wondering
have you been here at the magic wall
since the election yes i have i've been
right here occasionally i lean in get a
little nap it means it fits pretty nice
here
we got nice graphics here the sit room
graphics up here right now but i can use
the maps
i helped santa with some logistics very
important this election year keep those
georgia runoffs in play and
also we have homing devices on kenny
chuck and shaq and i used the map to
track them
we could do everything just yesterday
here in the situation it's amazing we're
following john some
major developments joe biden or kamala
harris they won't be the only new
residents
here in dc bradley beal has himself a
new running mate
the former mvp russell westbrook was
moved from the lone star state to
hopefully energize
our city john that has been shall we say
deeply divided it has been deeply
divided we'll see if russell westbrook
can
bring the wizards together i hope we get
to get into the arena this year and
watch that
westbrook now coming here to washington
traded for the longtime washington
insider john wall who's relocating
to harris county houston congresswoman
sheila jackson lee's 18th congressional
district down there in texas and like
many people we know wolff
john wall hoping getting out of
washington will give him a fresh start
meanwhile the houston rockets are hoping
get the pun wall won't be there
lone star going forward i get the pun
very good you got good material over
there arizona john was a swing state
last month
and went blue chris paul the head of the
nba players association
has been relocated to the grand canyon
state to play with sharpshooter
devin booker the 35 year old union
leaders bones
should enjoy some solar powered fun with
the suns don't you think
i don't think age would be an issue i
don't know why we say he's 35 but you
know shaq did send me some icy hot for
those long days standing here
during election week maybe i'll send
some out to cp if he's having any issues
warming up about
l.a wolf lebron and his lakers hoping to
re-elect themselves to use another term
there to another term
as nba champions that would make the
lakers the most decorated franchise in
league history
the reigning sixth man of the year
montrez harrell he must love l.a county
in california's 34th congressional
district
so much he decided to stay in los
angeles but
in politics we would call it switching
parties in basketball they call it
switching locker rooms going over to the
lakers staff
very interesting indeed and john as you
know these are not the only seats
that change during the off-season but
some of the more shall we say
interesting transactions uh give us a
thought what are you looking for you're
a big nba fan i'm a big nba fan
what are you looking for hopeful for the
wizards i live here as you know by birth
i'm a celtics fan celtics have this big
trade exemption they got from the
gordon hayward trade i'm waiting to see
what they do with that we'll have to
wait a couple of months for that
plus doc rivers back in the east my
celtics championship coach
glad to have him back in the east but
i'm not going to root for the sixers
story
no way uh i like to i like all the teams
but the wizards
i'm a season ticket holder i love the
wizards have loved the wizards for many
years ask me what i'm looking for
in this season hey wolf what are you
looking for most in this season
that's a good question john thanks for
asking me that question uh
the wizard's number one draft pick i
have really high hopes
denny of dia from israel he's six nine
uh he's
only 19 years old played in israel as
play-doh
in europe he is really really good he
can dribble he can shoot the whole nine
yards
i'm hoping he does it for us i watched
his hanukkah video it was awesome it was
playful it was fun it was colorful
i hope he can shoot a little better than
he sings i heard one nba announcer call
him
the mensch on the bench we'll see if
he's on the bench or if he's on the
court let's hope he's on the court
and he's playing john thank you very
much that's it for me that's it for john
king we're here
in the situation room to all of our
viewers here in the united states and
around the world thanks very much for
watching let's get back to
ernie johnson in atlanta
i'm telling you right now there is no
way that cnn would ever put us on their
air on election night but we will put
them on our air on opening night
excellent job
well done those are nice well done they
are awesome loves
them at the all-star game every year
exactly